what's going on guys this is rob and i
have a theory about wanda that's kind of
based off an existing theory but we're
actually going to turn it on his head
and we're going to shift it up so you
remember in like the different doctor
strange trailers we get all this kind of
footage and all this crazy footage well
some of the footage that we got one
scene in particular shows like wanda on
her knees and then a wanda walking up to
the wanda who's on her knees now the
prevailing theory there is that because
we're dealing with doctor strange into
the multiverse of madness that we're
talking about variants in the same way
that sylvie is a variant of loki one of
those wandas is a variant of wanda from
the main marvel cinematic universe i
don't think that's true and i think
what's actually happening is i think
they're both wanda specifically they're
both the same wanda from the marvel
cinematic universe which begs the
question are we dealing with something
like time travel no so here's the thing
right here's here's this this is i don't
know this is true but i feel like it'd
be awesome if it was so let's look at
comics for a second right and let's just
move away from scarlet witch in comics
for a second let's talk about adam
warlock so in in marvel comics you guys
have all heard of a story called the
infinity gauntlet right thanos gets the
infinity gauntlet he blinks out half
life in universe yadda yadda his
daughter nebula who looks like a meth
head at that point in time gets the
gauntlet and then goes crazy and then so
on and so forth and at the end of the
story adam warlock gets the infinity
gauntlet for himself and he ends the
conflict okay follow that story up what
you got was something called warlock and
the infinity watch now the idea behind
this is that adam warlock having the
infinity gauntlet had essentially
decided that a person being in
possession of it that it was just too
much power now this decision was also
kind of forced on him in the sense that
as soon as adam warlock had gained the
gauntlet and after the infinity gauntlet
story was over he was put on trial by
the cosmic entities with a living
tribunal presiding as judge and what the
cosmic entities were arguing is that
adam warlock is incapable of being a
person to hold the infinity gauntlet
just because of the fact that there's
something about him that basically
removes him from being able to
understand right and wrong which didn't
make any sense because we knew that adam
warlock was traditionally a hero he
understood right and he understood wrong
he let his timber get the better of him
which basically led the living tribunal
to believe the cosmic entities and
essentially the infinity gauntlet or at
least the infinity stones were
completely and totally shut down and
adam warlock was instructed to hand the
stones over to individuals that he
trusts and so he formed the infinity
watch thanos got the reality stone then
there was like pip the troll and there
was moon dragon who's the daughter of
drax destroyer and a few other people
here and there but basically it was a
loose-knit team of people each of which
had an infinity stone and they would
basically guard it now fast forward to a
story called infinity war and that was
basically this evil alter ego of adam
warlock named the magus who was trying
to get the infinity gauntlet and all
that kind of stuff what you learn in
that story is the reason why the cosmic
entities had basically argued that adam
warlock could not be a righteous and
true ruler because he couldn't truly
understand right and wrong is because
when adam warlock got the infinity
gauntlet subconsciously he had basically
created or brought back the magus and
then created goddess and that explained
how it is that the magus had seemingly
returned after having been previously
killed and so the magus represented the
purely evil side of adam warlock and
goddess represented the purely good side
of adam warlock and then adam himself
was devoid of good or evil now i'm not
saying that's exactly what happened
insofar as like a good witch you know
the wicked went to the east and the
wicked witch of the west but what i am
saying here is it's entirely possible
that when wanda became the scarlet witch
she purged that evil part of herself and
that's the version that we see whether
or not she's aware of that of that
version of herself it's completely
irrelevant and in fact i would say she's
not and the reason why is because if you
look at the post-credits scene of the
events of juan division that you have
wanda sitting on on like the little
patio thing in the front of her house
drinking or at least you know seemingly
drinking tea or whatever she's doing and
she ends up going back inside and then
the camera keeps going and it goes
around the corner and then you get wanda
who's reading the darkhold now this
could be interpreted a couple different
ways either that version of wanda is
literally there she's actually and truly
there or that version of wanda is just
kind of the the evil version of wanda
who's there but kind of existing in the
subconscious whatever it is i would say
somewhere between one division and the
start of doctor strange too that wanda
had subconsciously or maybe even
intentionally purged that evil part of
herself and that version is out there
and that's the one that's wreaking all
this havoc and doing all these things it
would explain how it is that wanda is
the main villain of doctor strange too
it would explain why it is that we have
two wandas and it would explain how it
is that we have that scene where doctor
strange is dressed normally and talking
to wanda and then in turn there's
another scene in the trailer where he's
talking to wanda who's got the whole
scarlet witch and everything's all red
but doctor strange is still dressed the
same that he's in the exact same
location but it's evil wanted that he's
talking to instead of good wanda now
coming off the heels of like moon knight
people might look at that and say okay
like multiple personalities and all that
kind of stuff like we kind of done this
dance before but there's precedence for
this there's precedence for somebody
attaining a huge level of power and then
in turn breaking off pieces of
themselves getting rid of that evil
stuff or that evil self becomes kind of
its own thing and then goes out and does
its own thing so i think that's kind of
what's happening here and doctor strange
too i think it's entirely possible that
what's going on is that we have two
versions of wanda we have the evil wanda
and we have the good wanda and perhaps
that particular scene where you have
like wanda in like the white shirt but
looks menacing and then you have like
wanda who's on her knees and she's
crying that's her being overtaken by her
uh evil self right she's basically a
prisoner in her own mind while her evil
self just runs around using her powers
and does all kinds of crazy things who
knows right i have no idea but this
seems like something they would do in
doctor strange too right because one of
the things that's kind of happening
because if we if we look at the the fate
trailer and we made a video about this
yesterday where we were talking about
how those monster things you know looked
like they were in the angari as far as i
was concerned one of the things that you
guys pointed out is that it's entirely
possible wanda was just using the power
of the darkhold to fabricate those
things to bring those things out but
even if that's the case one of the
things to know is we don't know exactly
how far reaching the dark hole is and we
don't know exactly what it is that it's
capable of much of what we're dealing
with here in doctor strange 2 is delving
into the realm of things that we just
haven't seen in the marvel cinematic
universe universe before so the rules
are gone right i mean like the the
gloves are off i mean it's just kind of
whatever we want it to be and if we were
for example to say that despite becoming
the scarlet witch wanda had never really
let go of all that anger and all that
pain and all that hurt even when i mean
that that's kind of indicated by like
the end of the post-credit scene in one
division when she hears the voice of her
kids it's not as though she's let them
go and it's just like my children are
not real i created them like she hears
them and then presumably just races off
so she hasn't let that part of her life
go and if that's still stuff she holds
on to it's entirely possible that if
she's messing around with the dark hole
and doesn't know what she's doing that
what she ends up inadvertently doing is
giving a physical form to all that pain
rage and anger that she's experienced
over the course of her life it's the
darker half right it's the darker side
of herself it's like the dr jekyll mr
hyde except for her it's miss hyde and
miss hyde is walking around as a
separate tangible being and so
ultimately it's good wanda helping
doctor strange and those guys defeat
evil one who knows again this is just a
theory it could very well be the reason
why we have those two versions of wanda
in that trailer is just because of the
fact that like wanda from the main
marvel cinematic universe is just going
around killing all her variants across
the multiverse why i have no idea i mean
i don't i don't know why she would be
doing that but i do think that there is
credence to this idea i think there's
credence to this particular theory and
so i'm really really curious to see what
you all think about this right do you
guys think that is possible do you think
that there is a better than fair
likelihood that what we're seeing or
what we're going to see in doctor
strange too is in effect a good wanda
and an evil wanda essentially right that
evil wanda basically took on a physical
form we saw her for the first time at
the end of juan division we just didn't
know what we were seeing and that good
wanda is the one who is just trying to
make peace and live quietly and was the
one going inside to drink tea and like
that's basically it right is that really
what's going on here is that really
what's taking place that essentially
wanda's pain and struggle has manifested
in a physical form let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
i'm i'm very very curious to see what
your thoughts are on this uh but thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace